[Applauso]
parlo di identità parlo anche di
periferie parto dal posto più periferico
che possiamo immaginare che sono i
confini e non intendo i confini
metaforici ma intendo i confini
estremamente concreti quelli che
separano le nazioni e che noi ci
troviamo ad attraversare tipicamente
quando viaggiamo per lavoro per turismo
ecco io personalmente quando devo
attraverso la un confine sono assalito
da un'ansia crescente che culmina nel
momento in cui mi viene chiesto il
passaporto
allora mi chiedo a perché dobbiamo
mostrare il passaporto alle frontiere
per esempio stefan zweig un
intellettuale austriaco del secolo
scorso piuttosto allergico alle
istituzioni alcuni tipi di istituzioni
nel 42 ricordava lo stupore dei giovani
a cui quando gli raccontava che lui
prima della prima guerra mondiale aveva
fatto il giro del mondo senza utilizzare
il passaporto
questo ovviamente oggi non è più
possibile quindi se noi attraversiamo
confine il passaporto ce lo dobbiamo
portare e lo dobbiamo mostrare perché
dobbiamo mostrare e dimostrare per farci
identificare
ma cosa vuol dire identificarci cosa
vuol dire identificarti beh
identificarti vuol dire stabilire che
sei tu sei proprio tu e non sei un altra
persona adesso schivando le gli abissi
filosofici che questa cosa in cui questa
cosa ci potrebbe far cadere perché serve
identificarsi perché se io a che fare
con te voglio essere sicuro che sia tu
perché a te è associata la tua storia
io voglio ricordarmi per esempio delle
nostre interazioni precedenti perché
questo lo voglio utilizzare nel momento
in cui noi abbiamo a che fare
oppure potrei
volerti o doverti garantire un diritto
come quello di voto però il diritto di
voto non può esercitare una sola volta e
quindi devo essere sicuro che tu non lo
eserciti due volte per questo ti devo
identificare oppure potresti essere
titolare di un sussidio che ti voglio
dare una sola volta insomma ci sono
moltissime ragioni per le quali dobbiamo
utilizzare l'identità e come si fa a
identificarsi beh gruppi piccoli se
siamo in gruppi ristretti quello che
utilizziamo ovviamente è la faccia
quindi dal guardandoci gli occhi siamo
in grado di distinguersi l'un l'altro
abbiamo facce tipicamente molto diverse
alcuni scienziati ritengono addirittura
che abbiamo siamo evoluti per avere
facce così diverse proprio per
consentirci di riconoscerci e
distinguersi guardandoci negli occhi
se il gruppo sociale la dimensione
gruppo sociale aumenta un pochino
possiamo utilizzare altri meccanismi
quello della fiducia reciproca quindi
possiamo per esempio io posso affidarmi
il fatto che tu sei tu perché qualcun
altro di cui mi fido ti presenta e ti
introduce se però aumentiamo ancora la
dimensione a un certo punto questo
meccanismo come diciamo un ingegnere eno
scala e quindi dobbiamo inventare
qualche cos'altro
da qui nascono i sistemi di
certificazione dell'identità basati su
kart entità sul passaporto emessi da
autorità nazionali in azioni che si
parlano fra di loro
eccetera ma noi non ci siamo fermati qui
noi siamo fermati a viaggiare per il
mondo e aver bisogno di sistemi di
identità per oltrepassare i confini
molti dei confini che oltrepassiamo
quotidianamente e molte delle
interazioni che a cui andiamo incontro
quotidianamente sulle interazioni
virtuali quindi oggi il
il numero il posto dove ci
identifichiamo sempre più spesso è
online on line la nostra identità ha una
dimensione che è digitale
questo è bello ma è anche problematico
perché sappiamo che le nostre attività
online lasciano delle tracce
noi generiamo dei dati che vengono
registrati e poi vengono utilizzati
venduti vengono messe in relazione fra
di loro per ottenere altre informazioni
addirittura informazioni delle quali a
volte le persone a noi più care vicini
non sono neppure a conoscenza c'è una
storia
carina di un padre che scopre che la
figlia è incinta perché a casa
cominciano arrivare buoni sconto per
comprare vestiti per bambini e lettini
questi buoni sconto erano stati inviati
da un algoritmo che aveva analizzato le
abitudini online di navigazione della
figlia quindi padre scopre questa cosa e
va su tutte le furie la storia è falsa
però non è del tutto impiegare per falsa
però è andata su moltissimi moltissime
testate online
non solo però non è assolutamente
inverosimile quindi noi crediamo questi
dati e non abbiamo il controllo di
questi dati sempre più perdiamo
controllo della nostra identità ora io
non so voi come la pensiate se la cosa
vi lasci tranquilli però chiunque decida
per sé
sappiate che fra una settimana esatta da
oggi entra in vigore un regolamento
europeo che si propone di rendere di
impedire questo utilizzo dei dati senza
esplicito consenso delle persone
interessate
e questo regolamento costerà le aziende
qualcosa come 8 miliardi di dollari per
adeguarsi quindi può non essere un
problema che considerate vostro la
comunità europea lo considera un
problema assolutamente urgente e mentre
nuovo in europa abbiamo il problema di
troppa informazione legata alle nostre
identità altrove c'è il problema opposto
pensate per esempio al dramma dei
profughi che perdono i propri documenti
non possono chiedere che vengano rimessi
perché le autorità che li hanno emessi
non esistono più
in questo caso perdere i propri
documenti non vuol dire soltanto perdere
la propria identità anagrafica vuol dire
perdere i propri titoli familiari di
studio di possesso insomma vuol dire
dover affrontare il futuro senza il
proprio passato ed è una cosa che può
essere veramente drammatica ma non solo
ci sono posti dove l'identità
semplicemente non è una pratica comune
registrare le persone alla nascita non è
una pratica comune per questo uno degli
obiettivi delle nazioni unite per il
2030 è di riuscire a dare a tutti i
cittadini del mondo
un'identità legalmente riconosciuta
l'identità legalmente riconosciuta e
ovviamente una condizione per poter
accedere a degli strumenti di sviluppo
personale e culturale finanziario
pensate l'accesso al credito
quindi dobbiamo dare un'identità a tutti
un'identità che sopravviva le guerre
come fatta quest'identità è
necessariamente digitale noi sappiamo se
vogliamo conservare qualcosa facciamo
una foto e ce la mettiamo sul telefonino
la mandiamo da qualche parte nel cloud
qui questa identità devono essere così
però attenzione questa cosa estremamente
pericolosa perché un'identità schedare e
raccogliere tante informazioni personali
sulle persone e metterle digitalmente in
un archivio può essere qualcosa di
estremamente pericoloso per esempio
laddove ci sono in atto persecuzioni su
base razziale oppure su base
oppure su base culturale su base
religiosa immaginate cosa terribile si
potrebbe fare appunto avendo a
disposizione tutte le informazioni di
tutti i cittadini anche in questo senso
quindi l'informazione che l'identità che
noi vogliamo definire attenzione perché
quella digitale può essere problematica
riflettendo su questi temi si sono
definiti e dei principi ai quali la
identità digitale il futuro dovrebbe
rispondere allora la persistenza della
portabilità sono organi ho appena
parlato qua c'e nessun altro paio che
secondo me sono estremamente
interessanti
una il consenso l'identità digitale non
dovrebbe essere accessibile a nessuno
senza il consenso dell'interessato
quindi io ti dico chi sono ti do
informazioni su di me ma soltanto se lo
decido io
altrimenti tu non puoi accedere un altro
principe estremamente interessante è la
minimizzazione dell'informazione che
vuol dire io devo poter ti dovrei
poterti dare soltanto l'informazione
minima che serve alla nostra interazione
quindi se per esempio tu vuoi sapere
perchè se è un agente di polizia se io
sono abilitato alla guida io dovrei
poterti mostrare una patente un
certificato che ti convinta del fatto
che io posso guidare senza dirti dove
sono nato quando sono nato o magari chi
come il mi chiamo e può essere un
indizio di caratteristiche potrebbero
essere che potrebbero essere
discriminatorie
ora questi principi sono meravigliosi se
li leggete magari il dubbio se sia
possibile effettivamente realizzare un
identità con questi con che soddisfi
queste proprietà effettivamente alcune
sono un pochino paradossali come faccio
a convincerti che posso guidare che ho
la patente e senza dirti il mio nome nel
campo della identità digitale questo è
un tema assolutamente caldo è una delle
possibili architetture che potrebbero
consentire realizzare questi principi
l'identità basata su affermazioni o su
certificati alla come funziona questa
identità funziona così io sono il
titolare di tutta l'informazione che mi
riguarda ci sono delle autorità che
emettono delle affermazioni su di me per
esempio politecnico di milano
dice che io mi sono laureato pure la
motorizzazione che dice che io posso
guidare la macchina oppure magari la
banca o il mio gestore energia elettrica
che dice che è solo un buon pagatore di
bollette
queste informazioni mi vengono
consegnate mi vengono consegnate
attenzione crittografate in modo che
soltanto io possa decrittarlo e questo è
fondamentale perché altrimenti queste
informazioni io le terrò sul telefonino
oppure le terrò registrate da qualche
parte nel cloud
qualcuno potrebbe entrarvi in possesso
se qualcuno entra in possesso può sapere
tutto di me
queste devono essere crittografate
soltanto io posso decretarlo dopo di che
cosa me ne faccio
beh per esempio se cerco un lavoro posso
convincere il potenziale datore di
lavoro che io effettivamente ho una
laurea come faccio mostro questo
certificato e come fa lui essere
assolutamente certo che questo è stato
emesso dal politecnico con una
tecnologia che ormai tutti utilizziamo
sappiamo esistere essere accessibile che
la firma digitale
se invece voglio aprire un conto in
banca faccio vedere un altro aspetto
della mia identità e magari tengono a
scossa la mia laurea anche se non c'e
ragione però ipoteticamente potrei
volerlo fare quindi potrebbe sembrare
che tecnologicamente abbiamo tutto
quello che ci serve perché abbiamo la
firma digitale abbiamo la crittografia
possiamo questo sistema funziona manca
qualcosa che cosa manca manca la
possibilità di revoca per esempio se dio
non voglia la
motorizzazione decide di revocarmi la
patente è come funziona io ho un
certificato che dice che la patente ce
l'ho
l'agente di polizia come fa sapere che
la mia paziente è stata revocata una
cosa una soluzione potrebbe essere
utilizzare un registro che è
utilizzabile e leggibile globalmente su
tutto il pianeta quindi un registro su
cui tutti possono scrivere e da cui
tutti possono leggere informazioni
cioè siamo registro così la
motorizzazione potrebbe scrivere
l'informazione che la mia patente non la
mia patente ma quella particolare
patente è stata revocata
il poliziotto potrebbe control agenti
polizia potrebbe controllare esiste un
registro del genere certamente sì e
twitter lo vedete per il lungo nella
slide si stava altrimenti qui possiamo
usare twitter per revocare i certificati
quindi immaginate la motorizzazione che
scrive patente questa qua non è più
valida e l'agente di polizia quando
contro la patente va a leggere a buy ed
è usare twitter talmente no ovviamente
perché chi ci garantisce che
l'informazione non verrà cancellata
twitter a una società s chiude e poi il
potere nelle mani twitter sarebbe
assolutamente spropositato e noi non
vogliamo che questo succeda quindi
invece di usare twitter basterà usare
facebook
no non è vero ovviamente esiste un
registro così che non appartiene a
nessuno che garantisce che le
informazioni non venga cancellata
sì esiste si chiama block chain che
cos'è la block chain la block chain è la
tecnologia che sta alla base qualcosa in
cui tutti avete sentito parlare che sono
i bitcoin con la brooks chain se volete
è un twitter in cui ogni messaggio viene
convalidato da una grande quantità delle
persone che contribuiscono a questa rete
ogni messaggio viene cimentato in
qualche modo ai messaggi precedenti la
gente lo fa per far funzionare bitcoin
ma questa stessa tecnologia può essere
utilizzata per scrivere per esempio
delle revoche ed essere sicuri che
queste non saranno mai cancellate quindi
utilizzando una tecnologia che serve per
qualcos'altro
la block chain possiamo revocare i
certificati manca qualcosa sì se il
politecnico
speriamo di no perde la chiave con cui
firma le lauree
come si può fare bene con la blog chain
si può risolvere anche questo problema
si possono fare dei contratti
elettronici con cui si implementa la
buona vecchia fiducia sociale quindi se
dieci persone cento quello che si decide
convergono nel dire che il politecnico
ha perso la sua chiave quindi bisogna
dargliene un'altra questo si può fare e
quindi le autorità possono essere
revocate esattamente dalla società
esattamente come succede per i
certificati ed essere rinnovate chain
però persona tura pone anche dei
problemi tipo diritto all'oblio
come si fa a cancellare informazioni in
un registro dove per sua natura nulle
cancellabile oppure come si fa a
controllare i dati che i dati non vadano
all'estero cosa che gpr per esempio
vorrebbe fare se questa rete è
dappertutto nel mondo
questi sono problemi aperti e vedremo se
saranno risolti l'identità è una
questione complicata io
secondo me chi ci ha capito di più letto
questa cosa provo a dir la memoria voi
potete leggerla
io mi costruisco di continuo e vi
costruisco e voi fate altrettanto e la
nostra costruzione dura finché non si
sgretoli il materiale delle nostre
emozioni e dei nostri sentimenti e duri
il cimento della nostra volontà questo
secondo me è la cosa più completa che si
possa dire sull'identità grazie mille
[Applauso]